the new trailer for the long awaited
chainsaw man anime from
mapa studios has dropped and it's safe
to say that
fans are hyped myself included
now i know what you're all thinking what
anime culture corner post tonight i
thought he said he couldn't
well i forgot there was a chainsaw man
trailer coming out last night
and uh i mean screw it i could not
resist
so i reluctantly set up my new computer
very
very reluctantly i woke up this morning
and
the trailer it was like an early
christmas present
the animation looks incredible the lack
of censorship in the trailer is a really
good sign going forward and
it all just looked really really crisp
and oh my god makima
[Applause]
someone call the cops because bro we got
a new wave of makima stands coming and
they're about to get up to no
good none at all the show isn't even
animated we got like
two seconds of her in the clip and she's
already doing things to me like oh
sheesh if you didn't know already if
you're going to this video without
reading chainsaw man or hearing about it
beforehand
chainsaw man is one of the biggest names
out in shonen jump right now
and it certainly set a new precedent for
a new level of maturity and gore
in shonen manga it is part of what we
colloquially refer to as the dark trio
in shonen jump consisting of the
recently finished hell's paradise
the currently on hiatus series jujitsu
kaisen which i'm sure you all know
and of course chainsaw man which isn't
actually serializing right now as we
wait for part two
man i didn't even realize none of them
are coming out with chapters right now
seriously deprived of dark manga at the
moment
anyway having read and enjoyed all three
of these series
chainsaw man definitely stands out as
the darkest and
probably the most unique i think the
other two while
still generally having more explicit
violence than normal shonen manga
there's still a lot of shonen tropes and
similarities that chainsaw man
really doesn't have it makes it the dark
horse of jump even among these three
and as such it has attracted a huge cult
following
chainsaw man is beloved by fans for the
depths to which it goes and complete
absence of any kind of censorship or
restrictions as it depicts some of the
most
beautiful violence to grace the pages of
mainstream manga
i made a video about it a while ago back
before i even had like a thousand
subscribers which you can check out if
you want a little bit of my insight into
the actual manga and
my thoughts on it but to summarize that
like for something minute video
i love it i love chainsaw man i was very
excited for the anime i was gushing
about it and this trailer has
really gotten my hopes up but and yes
i know there is a but we do have to be
wary of
one major thing mapa
and look look before you get mad i'm not
the kind of person to hate on mapa
at all i think they do the best with
what they're given and they take on huge
titles with an
already massive workload that is totally
admirable
and they do great work but chainsaw man
will
either get the jujuto kaisen treatment
or the attack on titan season 4
treatment keep in mind how the attack on
titan trailer looked compared to the
actual anime
there wasn't a single sight of cg in the
trailer but just about
every titan scene in the actual show did
have cg in it
again no cg slander it was pretty
tastefully done by mapa
not to mention the way characters looked
was a bit different as well and
again i i please i want to reiterate
that i do not hate attack on titan
season 4 or its animation
but there is an admittable difference
between the actual trailer
and the anime i just really hope this
isn't the case with chainsaw man as well
because not only would that be very
disappointing for fans who just saw the
trailer
it would slightly put mapa's reputation
down even more
then it goes from being a one-time small
mistake to
a repeated one and precedent that really
wouldn't be very good
but to move past that possible negative
they could also give it the jujutsu
kaisen treatment which would be
incredible the studio isn't burdened
this year from what i'm aware at least
not with the year's two biggest titles
like in 2020
so i'm very hopeful that they can put
their everything into chainsaw man
and if you don't understand what the
judicial treatment is it's just
insanely good animation that's that's
all it is
it's pretty clear or at least i hope so
that they aren't going to censor the
show based on the trailer which was a
lot of fan's number one worries
especially with a series that relies so
heavily on great
violent fight scenes with tons of gore
so
if if it receives the jjk treatment and
doesn't hold anything back then it'll
definitely hit the ground running
chainsaw man already has such a strong
manga fan base and
with the boom that jujitsu kaisen
brought in the anime community
i'm confident chainsaw man's reputation
we'll we'll see the same thing
call me a pessimist but i have a very
difficult time getting my hopes up for
anime adaptations because
having high expectations almost always
leads to disappointment
but i really really enjoyed the trailer
the way the characters had this almost
like rough sketch feel to them they
weren't super smooth but almost had this
grainy and
rough around the edges feel to them
really fits with the manga
makimo looks hauntingly beautiful as
always and you can really see the
resemblance to jujutsu kaisen animation
in the monsters and character movements
here
so if we needed any sign it was getting
that treatment
i mean we've got it but again trailers
can be misleading
sadly it it wouldn't be the first time
now what do you guys think comment below
i mean the trailer itself
stand alone without any worries was
crisp
it was fire everything from the demons
to the characters to the action
if you haven't yet read the manga i
personally recommend doing that before
the anime
not only will it get you more hype but
you'll get a glimpse of one of the best
new dark manga and you can get ready for
part 2 as well
which i'm sure is like light years away
from being animated
plus if the anime does disappoint
then at least you have the comfort of
the manga but let's all keep our hopes
up it looks great and once again
i believe and put my hopes into mappa
best of luck oh and also if
if you're a real one if you're this far
into the video i've got a new series
planned out that's slated to be
released i don't know within the next
couple weeks about manga that i binge
read and
my review on them and rating and all
that kind of crap so
if you're this far if if you're a manga
reader or you want to get into manga
look forward to it i'm really hyped
about it and i'll see you guys then
or actually i'm pushing videos before
then so i guess i'll see you next time
as always this has been the anime
culture corner i hope you enjoyed the
video
don't forget to like and subscribe for
future in-depth show manga and character
analyses
you